right good afternoon everybody welcome
to the meeting of the audience
governance committee on tuesday the 31st
of may
um
first item on the agenda
to receive apologies for absence as well
looking i think we've got a full house
here today
no apologies
second item
confirmation of minutes of the meeting
held on tuesday the 18th of january
um
i'll do a quick page turner
we start on page 3
4
5
6
7
[Music]
thank you doug and those in favor please
show
those wishing to abstain
and just saying anybody against
right thank you
um
moving on to the third item declaration
of interests members with interest
should refer to the agenda item describe
the nature their interest when the item
is considered
fourth item
agreement
of agenda items part one two
representation
we do have a part two item
[Music]
[Music]
unanimous
urgent matters brought forward mission
of the chair i have no matters myself
does anybody else know
right
moving on to item six
that audit reports issued to date
pages 10 to 15.
um
thank you yeah thank you so paul with us
from devil hitler
so i'll um just provide a brief summary
of the paper so this is as you can see
just after standard update reports
um reports themselves have really been
issued to the members to see in advance
[Music]
reconciliations were occurring as a
schedule
certainly for food safety
again
we consider as an experienced team
who are focused on delivering and
meeting standards
um dates and deals were being
handled appropriately
um
what one key focus was how the foods
safety team has
i suppose the the actual inspection
program since the uh you know october 19
emergency which
then left a lot there being
suspended
so um
and
we're content that the the team has got
us
um
the team is on track to
uh meet the target dates set out by the
food safe food standards agency
um and
going forward and starting to meet those
targets
that that the fsa is going to propose um
that's obviously not case for all
councils but for this council
they are on
track um the next next two audit
opinions are reasonable so
building controls um
as you can see we say the controls
framework is effective
related to the processing of
that applications and
timing inspections
um
947 applications were received
electronically which uh obviously helps
efficiency effectiveness in the area
and
customer satisfaction
is
good with
no thanks
um
the rest of the summary talks about um
the extent to which services are
covering its costs
so
um
it appears to us it's making an annual
loss of 80 to 90 000 pounds
um but it has a very high market share
so i think those facts of conversation
are about um is their scope to
review prices and to cover more of the
costs that
oh david paul sorry many apologies
because you've shared this report with
me i thought we should have asked this
at the time
on a
refreshing remember this morning
that with regards to the loss of the uh
building project after the allocation of
all that i asked
yes i understand it is okay okay maybe
just to explain from members so then
when you say a loss
doesn't necessarily mean the cost of
ability control salaries unless the
income was in 94 is it 94 did you say
um
18.
about 80
yeah 80. yeah so it doesn't mean there's
an 84 000 the cost of the employees and
the income that comes in there'll be an
allocation across the there'll be a
small recharge with the finance
department serving
the hr department the i.t department
fathering our council premises
so just not to give that contest
yourself and then there's president
didn't think that actually our salaries
obviously are inconvenient
[Music]
sorry i i'd actually bring that in the
report
to find out and establish what was the
root cause of this
but it goes on
to suggest
that we might need to review our charges
so that we actually break even
because we're not allowed to make a
profit in the service
yeah that's correct i mean i thought
there's two things on building control
the building control is one service that
we're in competition with the market
yeah you know direct competition there's
only the only statutory functioning
relationship to like dangerous buildings
so yeah when i read the interest i don't
know why i didn't pick up on it to be
honest apologies on the first reading
but when i read it this morning that's
something that jumped off the moves
today is to go we could have a look at
the charities but obviously i need to
have a sense of market sensitivity
yeah
so that would come forward
that will come forward to
cnr to
establish whether it's
part of the review of fees and charges
that we do every year it would be part
of the fees and charges
there is no way that we can rectify this
ahead of that time
in a special
report i want to commit my officers to
doing that just at this moment you can
do we
hire the delegated authority to
increase fees and charges if there's a
lot of income but i think it's more
you'd have to be a more fundamental
piece of work and being perfectly honest
well when we're seeking to say
80 to 90 000 irrespective of
why it's approved needs to be taken into
consideration yeah all i'm just saying
is that i personally don't know what the
market would take in terms of um the
building control officers would know
what we were charging compared with the
private sector
it's not involved we've interrupted you
well it's fine and just on your comments
so
there is a consideration about um what
would you use market to share i suppose
it seems you have 85 in the market so
can you take a small reduction in that
but you know and the second point i
think about the service costs i mean
obviously it's appropriate that they pay
for
their overhead cost of ip
and heating and all the other stuff
but um
anyway it's something that we've
surfaced for
maintenance
um so going on strategic planning yes so
yeah we were trying to impress that um
monitoring of delivery of our strategic
objectives
um and obviously
business reporting and the role of
internal scrutiny
how those linked down into some service
to the refunds and reporting and
progress and so on
um we thought those perhaps needed
to reference those aspects more in the
um
resource documents such as the
median of financial strategy um
and also um perhaps um identification of
its key
key internal strategies and partnerships
these are the key ones that we will need
to support um and you know as part of
our
supporting our strategic objectives
um and then finally so last one is uh
state management so um
unfortunately
we we provided a limited um
we lasted this two years ago and again
um limited at that time so um
the estate management post that itself
has been
vacant for a couple of years now
although during the field like it would
have been filled but we understand why i
understand that the officers now left
the post so it seems to be vacant again
um
so
some of the basic points are listed in
the bullet point such as having a sort
of attractive maintenance plan
um and overall so that's a management
strategy um
a single system to detail uh all the
assets
and support their their their
maintenance and so on which i those
we would say the
absolute absence of those elements may
impact on
uh efficient effective asset management
um
that's in place
we do have a follow-up um
proposed in the this year currently is
planned to look at it again but
as i said it is a concern that the the
officer who the estate manager who
wasn't placed into gripping it is now
gone
i'm so i'm happy to take any any
questions
thank you um
i like counting odds and i was going to
raise about the um
uh
the fees for the building
called building control
and i wondered what the exact i mean
more or less that's my question but
um can we not as an audit committee sort
of put forward recommendations to the
cnr or do we just leave it i mean can we
get it on the agenda
is there any way that we can i'm not
sure we can put items in on the agenda
but i was going to look at it anyway
yeah and i was i was
following on one base i didn't pick up
my my already this morning well that's
certainly something that we're going to
be fees and charges for the year ahead
that's something that i
look at i mean paul's just stated i'm 85
but actually i we're always aware that
our building control because australia
one of the few advantages of where we're
located we're so far away from the main
urban areas
that companies based out of the bigger
cities like exeter and bristol don't
really see the benefits in
touting the work so far away from where
there's
um the work's easier to do because it's
closer
so with that 85 percent just just
logical to me would say there's 85
markets yeah they sent this goal for us
to increase our charges
and reduce that definition
just wondered who who actually does that
do you just do it i would be really
getting wonderful getting one of my
colleagues to sit down with building
control
and see what prices they think
can be done and remodel it based on the
recharges and then you you come together
and you put that as a recommendation
yeah cnr approve all the fees and
charges
be on the issue where we do it with
india
and whether we've got the time and
resource to do it but we do it annually
that's one now i'd imagine that it
wouldn't just be going up by inflation
there'll be a sort of capture
yeah it was more the procedure that i
was asking about rather than the actual
thing on the um
strategic planning um the homelessness
strategy
um i'm a bit concerned that we don't
seem to have much of a homelessness
strategy and i was talking to someone
who works for on encompass
and they weren't sure whether they still
got a job next year so i mean i wondered
what the situation was today have we now
continued the contract within canvas
[Music]
yeah that was not about the home
mysteries
well if we're employing outside
contractors like encompass
how often do we review
the trade
to do with homelessness what we have at
the moment they're helping us out on
household support scheme so when people
make applications for the household
support scheme
uh they process those applications
determine what the person
warrants getting to support the
household support scheme
send through to us this person
please give this person 500 pounds that
could be food vouchers cash wipers
in terms of the delivery
[Music]
the encompass are going to employ their
own staff for no not that no how are we
employing encompassing we're employing
encompass at the moment to do the
household sports game i would hope while
i don't live it that will be employment
of march 2020 because the latest
incarnation of the household support
scheme was come by denver county council
will start in october and end in march
2023
so when that finishes
then we don't
[Music]
planning and
i think we have a lack of strategic
planning but that might be just my
opinion but yeah
um i think homelessness strategy is
certainly one of the things that we
should be looking at
um
estates management you've only got five
five points at the bottom you say you've
got seven does that that that includes
the seven of it
oh well i suspect it would be something
management plan so we're knowing what
assets um
are held their condition
and um
where mason's work needs to be done to
support them
yeah i mean i
i think that this is a really serious
problem not having an asset register and
not knowing what we own i appreciate the
problems with tom and that he's left but
have we've got any applications for a
new one
the simple truth is that we're sweeping
the wheel when of a recruitment crisis
in local government
we're simply not an attractive employer
at the moment
we have got an agency person in who's
covering some autonomous jesus tom when
he left also said he would finish off
the asset management in his own time
that weekend obviously different
paybacks i believe the asset management
plan is
essentially
in the dotting the eyes crossing the t's
point he's just fundamentally done it
and completed it the key issue is we are
struggling to recruit
people to do the jobs which they can
because you can see a boom in the
building
private sector can provide far greater
um
pay and remuneration than we can in the
in the local authority and that's the
reality there is no easy solution to it
we've gone out for two jobs i think we
get there's a stakes manager there's
another job i mean we didn't get any
applicants not one
and that's very
are we able to um increase the salary or
was it we're getting appreciated in
terms of
um a job evaluations game that the
council has signed up to
so there's a relative merits of in jobs
that have to be job related
i
don't have the facility within my own
team
one of my team said they wanted to go i
cannot unlock the private sector i kind
of just simply say okay i'll give you
five grand you're clearly worth it
and it'll cost we won't be able to
recruit somebody as good as you
i don't have that flexibility
that's the truth i don't want to give
you platitudes that
we're not facing this is a challenging
time
that's we've got an agency person in
who's doing some of the estate
management that vastly increased caution
to what we were paying before
we
we're obviously paying the agency as
well so therefore we are paying more
than people
yeah hopefully i'm for a short term but
we could not sustain those levels of
pain agency i'm trying to
if
some agency people in certain jobs that
you have to go down wouldn't be any more
than the chief executive
[Music]
well that gives us some food
rose you wanted to come in yeah i was
just going to mention on the estate
management on the final bullet point on
page 15 i can't believe that they
haven't completed that most important
task
listing and monitoring all the statutory
health and safety inspections to ensure
they are completely on time and i
thought that should have been a priority
yes we
we would agree we would for our
confidence we would expect to see this
is either install the inspections and
when they need to be done i think a lot
of the knowledge is in those heads in
terms of oh i know this needs to be done
at least i'm not listed down in
[Music]
your insurance policy wouldn't be
covered with it
doug you wanted to come in as well a
couple of points
just to pick up on the report that
president he was referring to with the
staff recruitment staff retention uh
david um
makes the point that he's not able to
just obviously give people a pay rise to
ensure that they
they are retained and booked now the
problem we've got is obviously job
parity because you know we're
you know we're a huge employer but we do
employ a significant amount of staff and
if you know if we
awarded
you know a
pay increase to one member of staff in
one department
the likelihood is you have to do you
have to make that sale award to more
than one person in that department and
then although the environments exactly
that would one uh also you know pay
increases so you know your
you know your wage would take a massive
lead if you went down that route but i
you're absolutely right it is it is very
difficult to actually
uh recruit new staff and to retain stuff
um you know it's um
we find ourselves in a really awkward
situation there's a lovely part of the
world to live in
but not everyone wants to come down and
work in the bus stop
particularly in orange there's another
there's a lot of other factors which you
know determine against that i mean
that's the fact is i mean just to be
take i mean it's going back now some
years since when i relocated to the
southwest
i mean i came from one of the poorer
cheaper housing areas within the united
kingdom
but it was still affordable for me to
relocate
there was a differential in the
comparable prices of houses but when i
came down
initially i could find eight nine
properties that percentage i could rent
yeah
and i think if the circumstances were
the same again at this time i wouldn't
have relocated
i wouldn't find anywhere to rent the
other difficulty you have with certain
local authority jobs these are quite
specialized in nature in terms of local
authority
experience being a requirement you know
nobody else really applies planners
other than developers
um council tax is a unique
thing to councils by very nature
collecting business rates cetera
and if you think of where we're located
in reality you want somebody who's not
going to have to relocate with relevant
local experience we're talking about
college and council
and there's the opportunity between
ourselves and our colleagues at north
carolina council if he was in greater
manchester well that's not so much of an
issue because there's
13 14 councils within commuting distance
and people don't have to relocate
but the main reason i had my hand up was
um to do with the you know the go to
control uh
initial
point um
haven't got any idea of the percentage
increase that we would have to increase
our charges by in order to uh meet the
deficit i don't have the tougher my head
but i would i think you probably saw the
over 50 percent over 50 percent yes
well i i i it was going to be high they
were really like problems
um
inspection to try to control it but if
we were to put the charges up by 50
surely that would be leaving the flood
gates open
for the private enterprise you're
actually you know but that's getting
bigger
that's why you'd have a conversation
with the building control team yeah i
have zero knowledge of the sensitivity
of building control prices yeah but it's
no longer science to to see that that i
know sometimes you could put it you
could increase it by 50 percent
it does depend that doesn't say i mean
it still may be the building control
firms are based in bristol still won't
be sending people down to do work here
but i don't have that knowledge well if
that's the case then yeah it's fine we
can put it up by a significant amount if
we could still guarantee we're going to
retain that volume of work
thank you
okay right it's pretty clear to me that
um
we've dealt with the issue of
building control
we're going to look at
reviewing our prices and that will go
back to cnr
um estate management
yeah it's something we're going to have
to revisit and thank you very much for
the report paul for highlighting these
issues
maybe if we could put it on the next
cycle on the forward plan
to revisit it and if you'd like to look
again at where
we've made necessary improvements or not
and come back to the next meeting
and then we can take a further view i
think that's a sensible recommendation
to make so i'm happy to propose that
from the chair
catalog rows your seconding
all those in favor
yes unanimous
so we can move on from that
council
twice
i beg your pardon i didn't see it back
there please come in again i'm quite
happy to support
your proposal however i think um with
regard to the last point raised in
estate management
do we actually
monitor a percentage of inspections
completed in the qbr's
because i think this is a risk issue if
we're not doing these as was pointed out
and is it a qvr monitoring factor and if
it isn't can we include it i don't
believe it's in the qb and i'll stand to
be corrected but very confident i'm not
on the scrutiny so i'm very confident
it's not been the qbi
well it it concerned me as it has
my fellow members of this committee um i
think that was the other things we know
are in progress
um but that one i think sort of jumped
off the page
so i would suggest that we we actually
consider
making a recommendation that if this is
failing
that we do something very positive to
address it
can it be incorporated into qbr
discussion to be included in the qbi
yeah
right okay
so and then i'm happy you're happy to
support
that
with that amendment
right okay we're on the same page now
sorry to miss you um
um
right moving on to
item seven
the audit plan on pages 16 to 22.
yeah so this is our drafting
for
2253.
um it's it's based on seeking
coverage of most
areas over the sort of four year period
with positive purposes on agreeing the
22-23 plan
um so that's providing insurance of
course systems
covering strategic objectives and so on
so
it's informed by the
key strategic risks that we're seeing
um really really overall different
councils such as um
security
on page 17 the practices of the a chart
showing
um
the the natural allocation of days and
it's all different theories and so on
um
much of our focus is on the core systems
supporting the
council such as tax credits and housing
benefits and so on
um and then we have obviously other
audits
against the strategic goals
because
areas such as cyber security which has
as you know is a incredibly high risk
for everybody
and also information governments
we've got an audit on climate change
which i'm actually suppressing at the
moment
um
and in terms of you know meeting the
principal's target
and as you can see there's some some
days to
um to continue to focus on state
management and to assess progress to
implement recommendations
um
so the actual um
audit plans are from
page
page 18
um so i appreciate any any comments and
thoughts about
any areas
that we um
would would need to miss or if you're
happy
with the plan as it is
will you be monitoring monitoring a
carbon audit each year
and so that we can compare our set our
progress with other councils
on that you know how much foreign
we we've got nod in the plan this year
um i might say that i'm also leading on
all this in for north devon um with
devon uh
um so um that's informative for me and
with different councils so so we've got
an audit origin plan this year i have no
problem at all about bullying it's in
that next year it is a
which is a strategic objective of yours
to achieve the net zero target and it is
you know significant for everybody
so um
if community says
please can you've done that next year
then
it would be perfectly reasonable the
focus this year is on the government
suspects
um which is probably appropriate for the
progress it's at a moment whereas i
think next year we could probably
comment more fully on the actual
delivery and
you know projects on that
[Music]
our progress with other council's
progress
and um i was wondering whether we should
look at
the percentage of our carbon that we
reduce each year with a view to
or whether we should compare ourselves
with other councils on the actual amount
that we've reviewed each year
um so as a sound because
i mean it's clear that the strategic
target in the of course the business
report is not um
needs to be refined because it's not
clear
what what the target is
um i'm
aware that some some targets are some
district councils are further forward
um partly because um
they've been managed to secure
a big grants to decarbonize their
buildings and so on
so i know
we definitely have got a big big grant
from their leisure centers and they're
sort of it's a bit of a win-win in terms
of
reducing carbon also reducing costs and
also improving their maintenance
arrangements as well
um and suddenly temperature got a big uh
a big grant
on their office buildings and so on
so
i think some some
councils are far from those
well i mean
that is
very helpful because
it shows to me what we need to be doing
we need to be looking for government
grants
towards especially our new measures and
you know the state of pleasure centers
that we've taken back in-house
[Music]
the report will say that there needs to
be
an emphasis on priority on
having the shuttle ready projects
that can be
before if you when the next round of
governments
are of
the post
quickly okay
[Music]
doug you want to go and then i can
age 19 development management
just have a brief explanation on the
corporate
uh reputational risk and the
financial risk horizon from
isaac
john
i'm i'm not aware that research diseases
are sort of um
yeah indeed yeah this this would be a
high risk on the corporate displacer
um and as it says
on page nine day 19.
and the uh
time has probably moved on on that one
from when this is possibly done i mean
at the time the financial risk was if we
went ahead with isaac
so we would be looking if you remember
with ties at yards it was significant
from construction
costs related to it
and there was also future income from
the rental of
smart work offices
so yeah i understand that it was more
the reputational risk
obviously failed so is there a
reputational risk because the scheme
didn't go ahead does that work
i'm only
[Music]
come to you guys
yeah page 19 again then planning
enforcement i think that's not what i
needed more low is that because it's a
an understatement service that we did
it is not to touch yeah so is that why
it's not marked what i mean below
actually the mission that's um i i don't
know um
i don't know why it's not
what what would all the committee pursue
or suggest to be
well
i think it's for
the intense order to tell us what it
should be because
we're not we might have individual cases
you might have anecdotal evidence but
that would be only a very limited
snapshot i think really
the number of cases
and the resolution of those cases would
be what we would want to know from an
overall
panoramic view rather than our own
individual opinions so maybe that's
something that
we could come back and discuss the
community
so
if that could be a future
action just because of
some of the admissions
exactly
so obviously it's in the audit plan um
we wouldn't
enforcement and so on and how
the incidents
[Music]
okay
right so that we've highlighted
i'll come to you i've got you
um yes i'd like to
have a sort of explanation please of how
you determine whether something is high
medium or low
and why some of your high
risk
issues that you've identified
for example
on page
[Music]
2019
the development management is five but
it's not until year four
or one two no year three that you're
planning to
do an audit
you then go down a
in the documentation to page 21
where you have ethics and values of the
authority is seen as high
hasn't been seen to since 2021
and it's again
three years on
you go down to members allowances that's
seen as new high
no no prescribed suggestion as to when
um
social media and communications which is
vital to the smooth running of the
authority
again
high but not for some time
and the last one strategic planning
which you've alluded to is
of um maybe needs some things addressed
and there's nothing entered in it at all
so i'm a bit mystified
i
seek some clarity please
yeah so if you look there is a column on
when the audit was last done so
in some of those instances they have
last audit so the last one you mentioned
since you playing we've only just looked
at that
um
[Music]
um
in creation we audit down we
um
look at the corporate risk which so we
look at what other risk councils are
facing um
also or discuss it with david about you
know where the priorities are now um
[Music]
practically you can't cover
every single time and medium system and
process that
the council has got um
with the size of order plan we could
obviously
cover it if we increase the order plan
um but there will be a cost so um
there's a bit of judgment there about
which ones
to cover um
and
another another point is about coverage
because
whereas we might assess something as
being high but um
as with street fighting we were broadly
happy with it
but but actually um you don't always
spot
the areas of significant weakness by
looking at the other high ones so
um as we've talked about state
management that that's great as a medium
but um
there are some
significant weaknesses that we've
identified through through auditing so
it's not a science it's more
more
just we also make judgment from things
that would not be on a sheet of paper
but for example
probably 18 months ago now we had the
two people who worked in parking car
parking in the administration at the
same time
so clearly that was an area i when i sat
down with paul i said that's an area i
want to be audited it's not particularly
high-risk coffee risk wise to the
capsule
in terms of somebody getting away with
paying a car parking
so you know you make a judgment there to
change the priority on
the car parking because the
circumstances have changed i think well
correct me wrong we had maybe one year
where we
reigned back in the auditing of the core
um
system such as creditor payments and
main accounts which you normally do
every single year i think we bring that
back in because we were doing a lot of
business support we felt that focus
should be there but there's a key thing
that i think paul's alluded to there's a
finite resource in terms of money that
we've paid a debinary partnership so
there's always going to be an element of
matchmaking
both because what we can afford as a
council but also the resources are
actually available to paul
paul's not got unlimited resources to do
every order every year
i
do understand that
some of the things may not seem to be
such a striking priority but my final
comment is that housing options
and housing renewal which is part of the
work we are currently undertaking
looking at how we deal with housing
um
is not until
year 23
now i suppose one could argue that it
would be better to audit it after we've
done
and developed the best program
of how we're approaching the homeless
housing crisis
but whether we need it to keep a weather
eye on how we are approaching it and
seeing whether we can act
smarter in any ways to support that work
i would have thought might have been a
priority for this this year
that's my opinion and not the
professional officer opinion
one last point david just said
um that a department can request an
audit
well no i talked to him
[Music]
doing a new job and we're bringing in a
new system and i think i requested an
audio certainly when discussion paul
said we might need to focus a little bit
more time on the payroll because we
introduced a new payroll system at the
start of the pandemic introduce a new
system that's when you audit
managers can't request i'm not going to
be audited we haven't made some
allowances to
reschedule the timing of the year
but no i mean if everyone gets if
somebody kept saying i don't want to
ride it don't worry well that's a red
flag to me he's probably a red flag
so
can i just say so this is um
this is live document um obviously it's
presented to yourselves to look at it
look at the days the audits were
delivering and um
suggest that okay we don't want this
work done perhaps a bit do this work so
very happy you know that's the way being
presented towards the community is your
comments about actually don't touch
disappoint you as you touch this instead
you know it's you know your comments and
then secondly as you as the year
progresses
you know there's opportunities to refine
it and to amend it if if um
significant things come up or can you
look at this instead of then you know we
will we would do that so
we'll take
the
request from this committee as
that i think perhaps the homelessness
strategy
would be a good one to to look at
because i find paul's work so
helpful because it compares us against
other councils whereas i have no
knowledge of what other councils are
doing
you can see
how they do things and i think we do
need to learn from best practice in
other places
and um so homelessness strategy might be
a very good one to look at next year
yeah is it infinite well it's only the
housing options
[Music]
but remember
all councils
have different
ways of doing it are different because
their localities
it's very difficult to compare like with
like
i mean we are we have our own family
group
as local authorities and maybe that
might be
an alternative way i'm not going to say
better way an alternative way of looking
at it
but it's very difficult to compare
apples and pears
but
i i do take on board what you're saying
um
yeah
paul
um
i know that
you're
having a very challenging time with the
number of councils that dapp have to
afford himself but how
how far behind are you due to all the
issues with covid are you fairly close
to where you want to be with the
internal audits
yeah i mean um so our
overall kpi for the year nine to 10
audits and you know we've
delivered that from
and also you know we've recently
recruited so we are
complement
and that's a challenging environment in
itself
and during regular contact with all the
officers and david so
you know they all know where they stand
and everything
yeah that's right i mean
is is to be able to
present uh an informed
um annual shorts opinion
um
right um we just note that item so i
think we do be noted and we move on to
and your
final item
yeah so this is um uh jedi tonight eight
so this is um
our annual
audit report um so this unfortunate
statement
[Music]
and um based on our assessment of the
internal control framework uh risk
management governance
um economy efficiency effectiveness and
so on
um so so we're
we're
providing reasonable assurance opinion
this year as as per
last year um i think that the question
did we get is
um
where where does weasel statement
compare comparisons what other councils
get
get
and
i i'm not aware that there's any sort of
systematic study being done about
what those councils get but i would very
strongly think that the last job will be
for a reasonable assurance
which is ultimately absolutely agreeing
as you know this but there's all
different areas of
what's saturated
and satisfactory so
is a good opinion
um
we've we've done and the insurance
opinions
provided for for each of them
um
[Music]
which really underpins why we we're
providing providing reasonable assurance
we thought
that the full substantial assurance
opinions would mainly count on food
safety payroll and then the reasonable
but also for
them to insurance opinions
um so that that sort of underpins that
the readable along with
what else we see in the house in terms
of these meetings and transformations
and and other work that
we do
and always doing
[Music]
more systematic sort of cross cross
checks between different councils
um based upon data analysis and so on so
um
let's roll that out
and then um
[Music]
30
page 31 talks about our professional
standards the fact that we had an
external assessment um i've mentioned
before here
um which um provided the top markings
that also highlights some areas of
development and opportunities that we
need to focus on
going forward so um that's the voice
summary of um
what i'm going to say so
just does anyone have any questions
about the
report
[Music]
but when i first came on this committee
um the harbour services were audited and
they were found to be sadly lacking um
[Music]
have you done any audit since
since then that was a couple of years
back
[Music]
opinions
i think one of the issues was i think
both these harvard master
um and then also the pilot
had left
which meant there's a bit of a vacuum in
manpower
and i think um because of the
personality issues um they they sort of
um i suppose left person arrangements
for a bit um
i i think when we were doing the audit
we were aware that the
new um
mars would be appointed and was directed
by him
and
and so we were
reasonably impressed or certain that
that they would be
they would be dealt with there is um
however the overall problem with the
covering the cost a bit again
and
the fact that you know the um
they weren't getting about trade
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are on limited assurances do they not
come under estate management if they are
owned by the council
yes
i think the
deception area does report to the
merger
um
but my concern is and if the cemeteries
aren't owned but managed by say parish
council town council something awful
might have nike did it weekly when they
went in and voiced over unstable
rainstones there was a well let loose so
i didn't want that to apply cemeteries
were
managed by the council yeah under our
states management so i just wonder why
they're giving a separate heading saying
under limited insurance
[Music]
one area of concern there was about the
grounds mainstream contract looking
after centuries
[Music]
[Music]
and secondly i think we have some
concerns about the systems um
software used to record
you know areas about who was
in what place and what plot and so on
and the backups about that information
because obviously it's reputationalist
if
the council can't say this person is in
this part and so on
okay
okay
right i think we again just note
the report thank you very much for
coming today independently in person
it's greatly appreciated
and for what you do
thank you
[Music]
right we will now move on to item 10
which is the grant performed
[Music]
obviously our colleagues have a nordic
partnership just want to take various
artists during the year
and they
um make observations and propose agreed
actions so on the first page of report
there there's various numbers of audits
and various agreed actions which
actually came to around 100
and uh managers then agree
hopefully agree most in most instances
with the audit findings and give a
timetable when they will do
the actions they've agreed to
so
when i did this report there's 19
actions still open what that means is
that within the time period that they
manage the management said i'll do that
by x times
and that time is still open
uh there were ten that are in red there
which are late
and there are 71 that were completed
the next page um
just shows you the responses to the ones
that are
late i think i'm one of them about the
quality diversity something's gone wrong
there because the the writing just stops
after it doesn't actually finish
um
i can't say i'll always answer every
question on because these are the
responses have come from the managers
concerned
um so i'm happy to take any questions
which i may be able to answer
claire um yes
i'll put a question where it stops mid
flow i think
i think from
i've seen to recall that stacy said she
didn't believe we had a legal obligation
to do that she disagreed with the
um david's partnerships interpretation
of whether we had a statutory obligation
to produce such a report
however it just faces only this week i
only spotted it
this morning
so let's just leave that for valence for
now because i don't know what the
sentence was wrong to say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the risk management plan which
was about um securing an independent
member for this committee actually that
um
we had understood that
you know government is going to put
forth legislation that the committee
shouldn't have a independent member
about that or this
that legislation is
as i understand it sort of not likely to
come forth anytime soon so
um
that as a result the legal can't have
ones
well if it ever comes to fruition is not
currently there so
it's
desirable to have one but it's
challenging to find the right person
because of our location
and if we were in the university town
maybe we would find it easier to find
somebody with the
required attributes
it's a very specialist niche market
we're looking forward
okay um
and i think the business that we were
discussing earlier about cemeteries is
actually highlighted in
two of the boxes there which clarifies
the
introduction of new systems so i think
that's good reading
um
the
[Music]
other one
it's a question actually
the sam elf system
i'm sorry uh haven't come across the
sound elf
right about the database is it the name
of the database or yeah what i think it
does
i'll only give it a brief discussion smt
about it on monday where i believe the
system does it records when
energy efficiency surveys need to be
undertaken when some routine maintenance
needs to be undertaken
and i think what's happened is
the data
exists but is this in a haphazard
spreadsheet form and a chapter we've got
off the agency card nick i can't
remember his second name involves nick
argles nick arnold's
i know is getting that populated now
from the data that actually exists in
this day's department
quite progressive and i'm honest they're
quite progressive with that all right
it's great but i don't know what this is
absolutely yes like i said unfortunately
this is this is tom who the managers
who've responded so
item
nine
and move on to
grant thornton
update report on item 10 pages 40 to 60
on the agenda to receive a report from
our
auditors grant thornton so over to you
julie and you're
online i hope
yes i'm here can everybody hear me see
me
yes yes we can see you thank you
fabulous thank you thank you thank you
all and thank you chair
so um so the first we got a series
reports this first report is um our
progress report which gives you both an
update on where we are as far as the
2021 financial year is concerned but
also gives you um uh some initial
updates as to how we're progressing with
the planning for the 21
22 audit
um
i'm sure that the the main item of
discussion for today will be around the
progression and the completion of the
2021 audit
um and obviously when we came to
committee in january we did highlight
what was the last
few areas that we needed to resolve as
far as the audit was concerned
and i did communicate to the audit
committee at that point that we were
very close to completion and that there
was
a small number of tasks that needed to
be completed
now recognizing
if i could interject there you also
agreed that you would come back to me if
it was not signed off in a few days
and that's
you know it was stated that grandfather
looking for a quick resolution and a
close to sign off so i'd be very
interested firstly in what the issues
are
and secondly why
i hadn't got any communication
that
said why these accounts
were not signed off
well firstly chair i would apologize um
uh if i misunderstood the communication
i i needed to give to you specifically
on that
um in terms of the the audit itself i
said we're not waiting for any
information from the authority this is
procedures that need to complete be
completed from from our side as far as
the
audit is concerned
now
i recognize that that has been
significantly delayed since we gave
those assurances to the last audit
committee but in very much a similar
situation to what paul has described um
we've had a number of other issues
happening elsewhere with some of our
other clients and also
some some further subsequent matters
that have arisen broadly within local
government um that whilst doesn't have a
an impact specifically on torridge is
having a considerable impact on a number
of the other audits that i personally
have to deal with so this is not about
any blockages or concerns with your
authority this is about
my team and my personal capacity to be
able to
manage a number of different
um
constraints on my time over the last
couple of months so
um i absolutely recognize that the
committee will be very disappointed that
we've not concluded this work
but in much the same in much the same
way that that paul and and um and david
has described there is you know limited
capacity and a finite amount of time
that both myself my colleagues have
um and we've just not been a position
that we can conclude yet
can you hear me
julie can you hear me yes i can hear you
okay sorry i've been trying to um
[Music]
to
get a point across
what actually are the issues that have
prevented completion
without going to too much detail of the
individual tasks so actually doing the
detailed testing with the authority is
only a certain proportion of the work
that is done to complete an audit
process so once the audit testing is
effectively done there are a number of
completion procedures that we to make
sure that we fulfill all of our quality
requirements and all of the auditing
standard compliance that we have to
prepare and complete from our side
um to effectively um
look at the audit as a whole take stock
of of all of the evidence that we have
effectively stand back from the work
that we've completed and be absolutely
comfortable before i put my my signature
to the bottom of an audit opinion i am
satisfied that i am given the right
opinion and that i've got the evidence
to to support that so it's effectively
those stand back and completion
procedures that's a very important part
of my process in terms of that quality
assurance that needs to be completed so
this is not that need work that needs to
be done this is not working
you could just pause a little bit
so that this committee can better
understand what those procedures are
please could you enlighten the committee
as to what the delay actually is
why we have
a set of accounts
that are 14 months
overdue
and we've got a second set of accounts
that are open and we're now in a third
financial year that we're trying to
input on so
would i be right in thinking that one of
the issues
is significant infrastructure such as
bridges
no
no that's not correct um the point i the
point i highlighted to david yesterday
was infrastructure is a big issue in
local government but it's a bigger issue
for some of my other audits that i've
had to
devote some time to
which is having an
effect on how much time i then have to
do other tasks so this is not an impact
for torridge but it is having a very big
impact on some of my other audits that
are also well-grown at the moment i hope
that helps clarify the situation but
infrastructure whilst you have some it's
not material at torridge and doesn't
impact on the outstanding issues for
your audit
okay so what actually are the issues
that have prevented
the delay in a set of accounts that
should have been ratified
some considerable time ago
so the issues are is my physical
capacity chair and as
i'm trying to explain to the committee
um i only have a certain amount of hours
in the day that i have to work across
not just this audit but a number of
audits and there are some other more
significant matters that i'm having to
deal with across some of my other audits
that is restricted my available time to
conclude this audit
my concern is torridge district council
i i understand that that is your concern
chair but all i'm saying is is that i'm
trying to service all of my clients um
in the best way that i can
i have
i will enlighten you to the fact that i
attend
an external meeting with the southwest
audit chairs
and the external audit comes up time and
time again with grant thornton and i
think there's
more or less universal dissatisfaction
with the service that we're getting
now
we would like to hope that
somebody
from the deaf different council would be
able to speak
glowingly about the service they're
getting but i think it's it's absolutely
universal across the board from my
understanding
but the concern i have is that you said
you were very
close to completion
back in mid-january
days maybe a week away
and
we haven't heard anything from you
and it's a highly unsatisfactory chain
of events that you're describing so
what is actually preventing
these
accounts
that are well overdue from being signed
off
what you know you're saying
as i've already described here i need to
complete my quality assurance procedures
and and that is what i've agreed with
david that i will complete in the next
few days and dave and i are going to
have meeting next wednesday to finalize
the sign off of the accounts
why couldn't this have happened
three months ago four months ago
and please don't say i've got i've got
problems with time because surely grant
wanted to drop somebody across from
another area
because this is a complete red flag
sure if i can give some context to to
the situation with audits nationally
this isn't a south west specific issue
this isn't a grand thornton specific
issue
this is a much broader challenge in
terms of the the audit environment
across
all of the local government sector so if
i were to to explain to the committee
the position in terms of 2021 audits as
a whole
rand thornton have signed off by the end
of april 65 of all local authority
audits
all other firms have prepared and signed
off only 50 of their audits so whilst um
i appreciate that the southwest will
have a very um sort of uh particular
view of grantham that's because quite a
lot of the southwest audits are indeed
audited by grand thornton and so there
will be a much larger proportion of your
authorities in devon and the wider
southwest area that will have us as
auditors but the national picture is we
have a we have the largest proportion of
audits of all local government audits
nationally and we are performing a lot
better
than all of our all of the other audit
suppliers in the progress that we are
making so i think it's really important
context that we're not looking at just
one or a handful of audits in isolation
you know
our teams we have as much capacity as we
possibly can
from um
from the wide team to help service and
complete as many of the audits that we
can and clear the 2021 backlog across
across the sector this isn't just about
um you know a small number of orders
we're trying to manage that situation
nashville across all of our um
outstanding audits to bring those to
completion because it's not in anybody's
interest
that um that these um proceed longer
than than they need to
um because it just creates a bigger
problem for 21 22. and i think it's also
important i could get a word in it it's
very difficult it'd be better if i sorry
there's a little bit of a little bit of
time in different apologies chair
i think it'd be
a very good idea if you could come to
the next audit meeting because
all your predecessors used to come
by the last one
and it gives us an opportunity to speak
privately
as it says in the agenda
so that we could
we could better understand your position
offline rather than online
but
what i'm hearing from you is that
nationally between 50 and 65
of all the local authority accounts from
2020 to 2021 to 2021 yes
not been signed off no have have been
signed off so 65 of grand theft auto
audits have been completed and 50 of all
other firms audits have been completed
by the end of april in relation to the
35th of march 21 financial year
in effect
roughly half the capsules have got three
sets of accounts open
that is correct
what what's your thoughts on this
[Music]
so this is this is
this is linked to the work that um
satoni redmond did as part of the
redmond view it's a company it's it's
not only one issue in isolation here
it's a combination of different factors
it's a combination of
councils generally i mean in the general
sense
undertaking
more complex
transactions undertaken
new
types of services so you've got
authorities which um are taking
uh more risky transactions uh use of
more complex financial instruments
setting up group companies all of those
different complexities so it's that's
one angle of it
the next aspect of it is actually um the
constraints in terms of the um the
available availability of specialist
audit staff to complete this work
because
you can't bring a commercial auditor in
to do a public sector audit they need to
understand public sector accounts
um i need to be able to
um
recognize the specific differences and
nuances of looking at local authority
accounts
and and we know
nationally as far as the audit market is
concerned that is a big constraint um
and we for example have been looking at
a number of different alternatives to
bring in additional capacity to to
manage that in much the same way that
paul was describing it but the market is
difficult
at the moment in terms of recruitment
and that's not just within audit you
know david's talked about you know his
own challenges with with recruiting
staff it's it's not just within the
audit market that's creating challenges
but also then what you say julie but
david's team he's not had a significant
staff turner for five years he's been
dealing with all the issues with
ukrainian crisis the household support
and
we're getting things done
what i'm hearing from you
if i'm hearing you right is the
redmond review has led to the collapse
of the external audits
of councils is that what you're more or
less saying combined with the lack of
staff recruitment
no so the redmond review is in direct
response to the challenges in the audit
market so saturnian america was
commissioned by government
to try and understand what the root
causes of some of these challenges were
okay
okay
right i'll let you continue on
so so just so just finishing off
terrifying in terms of the the 2021
audit so um
as i've agreed with with with david um
we
uh we have some time booked in the diary
for next wednesday which i will then
look to conclude
um the work to get those accounts signed
so that we can effectively draw that to
a close and put that audit to bed
now
that notwithstanding um whilst we have
got these final procedural matters to
finalize for the 2021 audit that has not
in any way affected the ability of us to
progress our 2122 planning and and
um initiating the work in relation to
that audit so that audit is still
scheduled on track
we have the resources booked in you have
the audit plan already on on this agenda
and we're looking to
deploy our team
in in early july to commence the um the
detailed work
on the 21 22 financial statements so
that aspect of it is is is is planned uh
and and and ready to ready to progress
so
um that's all i really wanted to
highlight in terms of the progress
report here i appreciate that 2021 was
obviously the important factor to
discuss so that's why i've given more
focus on on that but i'm happy to pick
up any specific points on 21 22 as well
if that would be helpful
i i think
i'll be very interested to hear what
david has to say as to why
there has been this delay in specifics
um after wednesday's meeting between the
two of you
you're you're deploying your team early
july
when could we anticipate to sign off
for the accounts that you're going to
audit into lies
external audit i understand we're
looking to come to report to the
september meeting for my progress report
okay and you'll come in
i'm very happy to come in person chair
thank you very much julie i'd very
greatly appreciate that
um i'll throw it into the committee for
any comments they would like to make
any questions they
[Music]
once have we uh you know we're here um
capacity issue and clearly ground
thornton's have a
major capacity issue uh as
judy says it's probably
reflected around the country i've got a
degree of sympathy for her position and
grandfather's position but they are a
large large company that you know they
clearly need to do better with
recruitment to actually get
sufficient staff so that we you know we
don't have these you know lengthy delays
that were experiencing i mean
it is unacceptable and i
this wouldn't probably be acceptable in
private industry local authorities i
don't know we seem to take it on the
chin
but uh you know
it's not good news put it that way it's
important
any other comments
david you'd like to come in
yeah julia um obviously we'll deal with
all these matters really on wednesday i
mean my observations are julie is you
know
i think the communication proactively
from you to the council could have been
better in terms of just telling us that
delays were happening and
managing our expectations in terms of
sign up and i think the other issue
i mean you might be more said in your
own words
the issues of other councils
with matters that don't really pertain
to tolerance district council but just
held us up so we've almost been signed
off at the pace of the year slowest
border if you were starting the most
complex logic we were caught up in the
wash of those ones um
[Music]
i hope that you sign off at september
but you know
forgive me about this moment having a
degree of skepticism at the moment we
will i certainly hope so because i
wouldn't want to have it
so my main thing with julie just just
going forward
don't hide the bad news from us just
tell us as soon as it happens at least
we know
you
if i could come back on that um
thank you for your feedback david and
absolutely we'll take that on board i
think what i would like to do
as an action off the back of this
meeting is one
chair reflecting your comment um about
having a private discussion i would very
welcome very much welcome that
discussion and i will um liaise through
karen to to to coordinate um available
in your diary to have a conversation
um i think the section second action i
would like to agree is that david that
we put in place
a routine calendar of meetings whether
it relates to the time of when we're
actually on site during the audit or not
um is irrelevant i think if if we can
arrange say a monthly or a bi-monthly
meeting to make sure that things stay on
track from both sides um i think then we
can improve the communication very
quickly but also hopefully then
um address any issues as we go along so
um chair if you're comfortable i will
take those forwarders actions and and
hopefully that will put us some way to
to address the committee's concerns
thank you very much indeed julie as
imagination are you talking from your
extra office or bristol just to give me
a sort of geographic location um so so
i'm actually sat at my home at the
moment chair um because i've had a
number of uh meetings in various
locations today so i'm i'm currently at
home
are you bristol-based or editor-based
well i i'm bristol-based and we we don't
we don't have an office in next to our
our office is based in bristol
i used to visit an exeter office with
one of your predecessors when i was
chair of auditing governance so i see
yes unfortunately that extra hub office
um is is no longer open so we just have
our bristol office now
okay thank you um
any further rose do you like to come in
yeah i say this bit talking treat really
but i do deal with grants alton um in a
much lower capacity if i have retail
council and i will always have to submit
their agar forms on time and if you
don't submit your accounts on your a
power forms and all your other relevant
paperwork you want they are fined
do the audit commission get fined if
they don't fulfill requirements
i i think i've got enough here to
further my discussions when we have our
regional meeting with southwest
audit governor's chairs
because this is a theme
i didn't realize how bad it was
i really did not believe how bad it
turned out to be and there has got to be
some
greater concern
that district councils half the district
councils roughly throughout the country
have not got their 2021
accounts signed off
i mean taking that one step further i
know of a small parish council within my
world who didn't submit their accounts
and they will find two and a half pounds
which is double what pretty set is
my goodness
church if i may just just just to
clarify the councillor's point that the
the arrangements for town and community
councils is is is under a separate
contract we're separate so grandfonten
don't undertake the order to town and
community councils
we we did a couple of years ago but
we're not as part of that contract uh
now we we just focus on
the the major unitary authorities
right
okay well thank you very much julian i
look forward to seeing you at our next
meeting meeting in person thank you um
i think it's a question no further
questions
[Music]
so we note
that item
and move on to
the next item
item 12 informing the order risk
assessment
i think we've just jumped over 11 the
audit plan we have jumped over 11 i beg
your pardon
i think the audit plan
we discuss some of the dates but we go
back to writing 11 pages 61 to 83.
thank you chair i'll keep this very
brief so so the conversation we've just
had about was was for the obviously the
2021 year um this plan that you have in
front of you is the audit plan for the
21 22 audit that we'll obviously be
completing the field work
for from from from the beginning of july
so this is just ensuring that we
uh fulfill our communication
requirements to the audit committee as
those charge of governance we're
required to highlight to you
you know where we believe our key
focuses are likely to be as far as the
audit in terms of what we designate as
our significant risks by definition with
the auditing standards
so um some of those are presumed across
all audits so they're not specific to
torrid
um some are torridge specific because of
the size of those particular balances on
your balance sheet um in terms of those
areas that require the highest level of
estimation and judgment therefore
require a greater level of audit
attention as far as the risk of it
having a material misstatement
arising from it during the course of the
audit work so you will see that we
highlight
the two presumed risks around management
override of controls
and around forwarding revenue
recognition those are um standard across
all audits
that we have to undertake a certain
level of procedures to make sure that
that doesn't present a significant risk
to this authority
and then we also highlight the other
areas where
are specific to this council in relation
to the work for
in relation to the valuation of property
plant and equipment and also the
valuation of your pensions liability
which um if you were to look at your
balance sheet those two effectively the
two biggest um items on your balance
sheet um it's it's not just a you know a
list of transactions that make that
number it's it's it involves a lot of
expert time from your your property
valuers and your
actuaries and determining the values
that then effectively go into those
accounts which we obviously have to look
at in detail
and review the key assumptions for so
that's why we're highlighting those are
significant risks
we talk a little bit more later in the
plan about what approach we have to take
in terms of auditing estimates because
that is also set out within the autism
standards how we need to approach that
values of our pensions
sorry again
no they're not no no i thought we were
waiting for you for a letter of
evaluation for
no no and uh
watching our
valuers
right okay
um
so that's all of you i wanted to
highlight today that the risks are as
presented in the plan and we set out the
specific work we do to address those
risks because that's not the only
balances we do audit work on it's just
we're only required under the autism
standards to communicate those in
relation to the significant risks but to
be assured we do look at the other
balances in the accounts as well
and there's a bit more information in
there about the team
and logistics
for the audit
and obviously we'll continue to keep you
updated on the progress of the 21 22
audit in our progress report at the next
meeting
okay thank you very much julie um so we
will note
thank you chair um just to briefly
introduce this paper to members um this
is a report that we bring to this
committee
each year at this sort of planning phase
of the audit and it's effectively as as
the name described informing our risk
assessment for the 21-22 audit so
we're required to make a number of
inquiries both to council management so
through david but also to this committee
as those charged for governance to
um communicate and have a two-way
discussion with you on aspects around um
fraud both in terms of
um
any known or um
or suspected fraud
um but also around the arrangements to
prevent fraud
um we we're required to talk to you
about compliance with laws and
regulations and we're also required to
talk to you about things
such as um uh significant estimates in
the accounts um uh related parties and a
number of other areas which which the
standards dictate to us so recognizing
that's quite a lot of
quite a lot of areas to cover we've
tried to encapsulate that all into one
single document which management have
obviously provided their responses and
commentary to
and we have brought this to this
committee for you to review management's
responses
and and allow the committee the
opportunity to make any additional
comments
um or observations on those responses
from your own knowledge particularly if
you think there's anything that you
think it's important to flag to our
attention
over and above that that's already been
highlighted by the council so this is
really just making sure that we are
giving you that ability to have that
two-way engagement with us on on these
issues and really just to open up to the
committee for any observations or
comments
thank you very much julie um do we have
any comments
okay we'll know that titan
thank you very much for joining us
online and i'm
apologizing for the the time delay that
we've had in the
the internet connection um which
made life little bit difficult
for discussions and look forward to
seeing in september so thank you very
much julie thank you
so move on to
item 13 which is our forward plan on
page 113
we have
raised a couple of issues that we're
going to add on that can just pop into
the
[Music]
but
if we just concentrate on what we have
in front of us at the moment
and david do you want to take us through
i think it's all fairly straightforward
just to knock it through yeah i mean the
iran fountain is the indicator we've
only really just started the
audit of the account for
2021-22 i would hope that we'd have a
draft set of accounts to go through
which is just simply to tell you how the
financial year was but they would have
i wouldn't expect anything from
grandfather on those accounts at that
time
yeah
could you just remind me to share what
we've done so bad i know we're going to
have the asset management plan well
since the advancement
[Music]
enforcement we wanted some updates on
the figures
i think they just dropped into the
mission
any admissions are on the audit council
yeah
[Music]
um so
we now go into closed session
i propose that we go to part two i have
a second different player
always